and now we and now we deviate back to
football uh
pete's saying stay on target yet again
after we went off target there for about
five minutes but yes i used to pee in
the trash can but but i can say this
under any type of sodium pentothal lie
detector i never peed in the trash can
at nbc or any other workplace settings
chris yes no but i've never poured water
in either so i got that going sorry um
okay
yesterday the ravens had a pre-free
agency i guess you call it press
conference i don't know eric decosta
spoke on a variety of topics and now
that dak prescott has his new contract
four years 160 million dollars if you
haven't been paying attention the last
couple of days lamar jackson is one of
the guys who's on deck for a new deal
here's eric decosta talking about the
hope in baltimore that they can get
lamar jackson signed to a second
contract
lamar and i have had a couple
talks we did spend some time together a
few weeks ago
and that went really well we haven't
really gotten into the actual contract
proposals negotiations things like that
it was more of a general conversation
about a lot of different things the team
lamar um
you know just how we were going to go
about a negotiation like this there's
definitely some different moving parts
that make this different than a lot of
other negotiations we've done so
i think from our perspective it hasn't
changed from what i said post season
which is lamar is a really important
part of the team
he's a leader he's an outstanding player
he's a foundational type of guy for this
organization
i really think he loves the organization
i think he's very appreciative of the
organization and in our stance and
different things
and we're confident and committed to
trying to get a long-term deal done and
hopefully we can get that done at some
point you know in the near future it may
take a little time but we're willing to
try
yeah the ravens understand that lamar
jackson is the guy the cautionary tale
of jared goff and carson wentz look you
know your quarterback better than anyone
and shame on the eagles and the rams in
hindsight for getting it wrong
especially the rams the eagles i i i
think that there's a little bit more
supplementation
stuff happens category right the rams it
was why the hell are you doing the whole
league was saying
yes right yeah why why why i almost feel
like they did it out of spite i feel
like that too to tell those of us who
were saying don't do it up yours right
we're doing it right but uh the ravens
know they have a winner with lamar
jackson here's here's the reality
because it's not like you walk right
through the door now if you're lamar
jackson and say give me dak prescott's
contract dak prescott's contract was a
product of his leverage and lamar
jackson is four years away
from having the same leverage that dak
prescott enjoyed he'd have to finish the
next two years of his rookie contract
one year of the franchise tender and
then be embarking on the second
potential franchise tag staring down the
possibility of being tagged before he'd
have that kind of leverage right now
this is the opportunity for the ravens
to do what the cowboys failed yeah right
right the cowboys failed to swoop in
when the window opened and make him an
offer he couldn't refuse you got to make
him an offer he can't refuse now because
that number is only going to go up and
up and up and up as time passes yeah a
hundred percent and you know first off
lamar jackson as we all know you know i
i don't care you know everything is
going in the right direction as a pocket
passer
you know he is a special special player
and without a doubt he is one of the
five or six best quarterbacks in the
game yeah it might not be done the way
that other quarterbacks can do it but
we're seeing development from him hey
the playoff game it's ten to three they
drive down he makes a number of great
throws and gets them down there yes i
know he threw an interception but i i
continue to see progress in the drop
back pass game and we talked about some
of the other issues that don't lend it
to being great for lamar jackson all the
time anyways the offense is not all
really that creative in the past game
you know there is no legitimate threat
weapon at wide receiver to dictate
certain matchups and get defenses to do
certain things that way too so you got
to take that into account and then mike
you you talk about the leverage thing i
mean you're right he doesn't have that
leverage that dak prescott does but he
does have a little leverage and one
similarity and where we talked about dak
prescott
and that team right now and the way it's
built at this moment where the defense
isn't good the run game's not special
anymore and their receivers are special
and they need a special quarterback to
you know make all that work and really
uh flourish and all that
well lamar has that same thing there in
in baltimore you know he has got them a
little bit by hey they've gone they've
gone all in on lamar and
building an offense that is unique to
only him really it's really him and
that's it that can do this type of stuff
so that's where he does have a little
leverage to go
oh okay you don't want me all right well
good luck trying to run
that offense or inventing a new offense
or somebody else next year let's see how
that goes so he does have that aspect
and i would think that baltimore and
decosta who's very smart
would realize that and you're right get
out of get on it now right get on it now
especially with
i would think maybe you could get a guy
like lamar who knows he he plays a
dangerous style of football to where he
might look at it and go whoa you you're
going to give me you know 85 million
guaranteed or something like that sure
i'll take it right now i i think it's
interesting and i hope baltimore can get
it done
and here's where it becomes critical
for lamar jackson
to hire
an agent don't get caught up in two
percent three percent whatever percent
and i think lamar jackson's got the
bargaining power at this point because
being attached to lamar jackson would be
good for an agent's other recruiting
efforts you can negotiate it to one
percent of the total value don't get
caught up in that because a lot of times
98 97 99
of what an agent can get for you is a
hell of a lot more than 100 percent of
what you get on your own the belief is
it's going to be lamar's mother and her
lawyer who are involved in this process
but one of the important reasons to have
somebody who's completely outside the
family bubble completely independent in
a position to say the things that need
to be said
part of what you have to say to a guy
isn't just
you know ask for more or ask for less or
here's what we want to get or here's
what you should try to get part of it is
to get the guy to say
there's value in waiting and to
understand the risk of waiting but to
see the value in waiting you know um
dak prescott i'm sure heard many times
chris over the past couple of years from
family members friends
teammates
who either were genuinely concerned
about him or maybe put up to it by
somebody within the organization we know
how the sausage gets made yeah even if
they weren't doing it consciously you
hear a coach talking about it here's
somebody else talking about it hey dak
are you sure dak that's a lot that's a
lot of money that's a lot of money to
say no to but think about that how much
is enough how much do you really need
yeah no i know
your life
right and and and so you you need
somebody in your corner who is saying
stay on target as pete has told us
multiple times today don't get caught up
in that don't worry about what they say
don't worry about them they're not the
ones who have to live with this decision
and and so it's not just
you know urging the guy
to push for more it's also urging the
guy to wait
for more sure and be patient and and you
need someone who's going to give you
good sound advice and also lay it all
out for you you get to a certain point
i've had agents explain this to me at
some point there's an offer that is on
the table that you have to say yes to
because what would you tell your own son
i can't say no to this
and and that's where an experienced
agent knows when you're in that sweet
spot that's why and yeah look i
understand that there's
it really hasn't gotten off the ground
because i think most guys understand
they're not equipped to make these
decisions because they're making them
once agents make them over and over and
over and over and over again right you
need a good agent who can understand
when that sweet spot arrives and when
it's time to say
i'll accept
uh and that for dak prescott it finally
arrived after two plus years for lamar
jackson
you know it could arrive quickly but you
better be sure you're taking the right
offer you don't want to regret it two or
three years from now no i mean listen
i'm always in favor of an agent you know
yeah it's
it's can be a pain in the butt and yeah
you got to give them three percent or
maybe you can negotiate and get
something lower than three percent but
you know the upside as you've mentioned
many many times to me is is far greater
than the downside in doing that here's
the next thing i ask you i mean do you
think lamar is realistic enough to go
like listen it's one thing for dak
prescott
you know yes he runs and does a little
of that but you know primarily a pocket
quarterback who's a really big guy
and with the quarterback rules the way
they are and unable to hit them and be
too physical in the pocket okay it's
less of a risky
you know proposition for a guy like him
than compared to lamar jackson don't
don't you at least view it that way
i i'd say yes
absolutely yeah but as you said the
ravens have retooled their offense for
lamar jackson they they are in a corner
here it's not like you can go find
somebody else and say hey go run our
offense the way it's been constructed
over the past three years so
look the dak press got contract yeah and
this occurred to me yesterday the
quarterback market was irrelevant to dak
prescott's leverage his leverage was
driven by the franchise tag and the
future
37.68 million this year is what he would
have made and next year probably would
have been an unrestricted free agent
yeah so they had to give him something
that made him say i'm not gonna do that
i'm gonna do this but now that he's
getting 40 million a year from signing
now that he's getting a 66 million
signing bonus now that he's getting 95
million fully guaranteed at signing with
75 million fully paid out this year
other quarterbacks are going to say
that's my barometer that's my benchmark
that's my f that's what i'm trying to
get to and so
uh
by waiting until dax deal got done
it does get more expensive for the
ravens definitely and and and you know
what maybe the ravens have been
frustrated
whether this was intentional or not they
don't really know who to talk to they
don't know who to negotiate with they'd
like to get this done and maybe they
would have liked to have gotten it done
before dak well yeah uh maybe maybe they
just thought that cowboys weren't going
to get it done right
but now that it's done that complicates
things for the ravens definitely and you
know you're right about not being like
listen people were frustrated about that
with lamar jackson coming out in the
draft you know not being in touch with
him yeah couldn't get in touch with them
you couldn't they couldn't you know
schedule interviews whatever it may be
to try to get to know the guy better you
know so i think that scared people
certainly now the ravens know him we
know that and all that you know the
other thing i always kind of chris chris
let me say this yeah go ahead one of the
reasons he went 32nd we've talked about
this before but let me emphasize it
right here right one of the reasons he
went 32nd he didn't have an agent
fighting back against whatever
narratives the agents who represent the
other quarterbacks we're throwing out
there to pump their guys up and knock
him down you need somebody who is both
defending you against that crap and you
know it doesn't hurt to be throwing some
of it back at some of these other guys
and maybe you do end up higher than 32nd
and maybe you're not the fifth
quarterback taken in 2018. no i i think
there's a real that's a real thing i
mean there's no doubt there was a
faction of people in the nfl who were
anti-lamar jackson as i've told you and
people that pushed back against me at
the owner's meeting that year when i
made him the number one quarterback
originally it was just it was constant
you know it bothered me you know and of
course i know bill pauline made those
comments but there was you know a number
of people out throughout the nfl where
yeah i mean
again it just was almost disrespectful
to him that way and you're right there
was nobody there to fight against the
narrative other than a few guys like me
on tv and and on the internet that we're
going wait what are you looking at this
guy is special he's the real deal now
the other thing i always get mike too is
this when i like talk about lamar
contract well
you know he's gonna slow down he's not
gonna be able to run like this forever
i i know that he won't be able to run
like this forever
but
it's it's not gonna fall off a cliff
here out of nowhere in the next three to
four years it's not you know yeah he'll
slow down
but he's still going to be one of the
fastest guys on the field as he slows
down he will he's a pretty he does a
pretty damn good job too when you break
him down
about not taking a a a huge number of
big hits he's very slippery that way um
but but i don't look at it two to where
well baltimore in three years is gonna
have to change their offense because he
won't be able to have the threat of the
run anymore no maybe it won't be
you know as big as a threat or as often
but that's still going to be there he's
going to be four years down the line and
i promise you if we made him run a 40
he'll still be able to run a high 4-4
and that's damn dangerous at quarterback
and and special and of course he's
growing as a passer too and the less and
less he can run
that'll force him to become a better
passer it's some it's a point my dad
always makes
you know those legs are get out of free
jail cards right you know that's what
happens to these athletic quarterbacks
at times because they just go get out of
jail free cards does that make sense get
out of free jail get out of freedom yeah
whatever you know get out of jail you
know what i mean
free jail but but but he my father makes
that point a lot to go in free jail they
pee off the porch yeah yeah that's right
just do whatever you want but but to the
fact of hey with a guy that athletic
he's always been able to get away with
going hey one's not open okay i'm just
gonna tuck the ball and run and i can
make something happen why risk me
sitting in the pocket and going through
the reed but we're seeing him grow
in that way and he'll continue to grow
as he starts to realize wait my legs
can't get me out of every jam in the
history of football here so i'm going to
have to start to push the envelope about
staying in the pocket and i see all
those things it is all trending in the
right direction for lamar i have no
doubt that he can do that and will
continue to do that as we go forward so
i hope they get it done i love watching
him he fits baltimore he fits their
style of football their attitude
everything about him screams baltimore
raven john harbaugh toughness we're
gonna kick your butt and from that
aspect like a dak prescott i think he
represents the organization in a really
great way and i hope they can get it
done
one more point that i think is highly
relevant here let's go back to the 2012
season the ravens were entering the
final year of the joe flacco rookie
contract he was a first round pick of
that team in 2008 and they didn't give
him an offer he liked so he bet on
himself he played it out and he got them
on the brink of a very difficult
decision
non-exclusive franchise tag and there
were multiple teams thinking about
swooping in and trying to take him joke
would have been on them frankly in
hindsight or exclusive franchise tag and
they they
decided we're not going to do either
that we're going to make this guy the
highest paid quarterback in football and
the way that their salary cap was they
had to tear it up three years later and
making the highest paid quarterback
again
they learned the hard way that holding
back right can blow up in your face i
wonder whether or not that's going to
influence their willingness and their
interest in getting this done now so
they don't have to ultimately make him
the highest paid quarterback in football
if they wait for a couple of years i
would think so it's a really smart
organization i mean we've seen they're
they're they're pretty damn good in all
facets of what they've done i mean
whether it was ozzie newsome and now
decosta and hey ownership everything
about them i look at the baltimore
ravens and go yeah they've made some
mistakes but it's never like anything
glaring man they've been
one of the most rare thomas well yeah
earl thomas that was a bad contract
certainly i mean i think they realize
that that's why they tried to get out of
doc they admit it they know
but like
other than the patriots
really i i challenge any like
have the ravens been the second most
relevant team over the first 20 21 years
of this you know century i would say
probably yes i think so when you talk
about it from all 21 years
and they're relevant every year they
contend every year right good every year
and uh that's one of the things you can
take to the bank as long as that
structure's in place with the cost is
the gm and harbaugh's the head coach
they're going to continue to be relevant
they're going to continue to contend and
you know you're going to be on the porch
you're going to be knocking on the door
and every so often you get a good chance
of kicking it in
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports